das corona chaos in deutschland falsche
prognosen panikmache einer der
bekanntesten corona politiker karl
lauterbach von der spd
er bezieht immer wieder stellung zur
pandemie gibt pressekonferenzen stellt
thesen auf buy build live stellt er sich
im corona kreuzverhör
die highlights
jetzt hat gesagt ich wäre dafür
verantwortlich gewesen dass wir die
schulen geschlossen haben und das ist
schlicht und ergreifend unverschämt und
schlecht recherchiert und falsch und sie
haben ja auch das zitat unterstellt ich
hätte gesagt die kinder wären treiber
der pandemie dann bitte ich sie ein
einziges zitat von mir zu bringen wo ich
sage dass die kinder die treiber der
partie mit enthusiasmus über im tempo
kann nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen dass
wir vor juli kaum eltern impfen werden
massive schul ausbrüche werden eltern
dann sehr hart treffen
in usa viele kinder einen elternteil
verloren das müssen wir unbedingt
vermeiden also man muss ja herr laut
aber bei allem respekt sagen da sprechen
sie ganz deutlich von massiven schul
ausbrüchen die kommen können waren also
davor dann ist es natürlich schwer zu
argumentieren dass man kinder nicht als
treiber sieht denn woher sonst sollen
die massiven schulabbrüche in den
schulen denn kommen nein aber sie müssen
doch das zitat also auch anordnung
verstehen
das war ja die situation dass also die
der größte teil der erwachsenen games
ist und ich habe dann quasi ungeschützt
im schulterbereich also die letzten
brocken die nicht dem send nämlich die
kinder und die eltern keine priorität
haben
dann bereitet sich natürlich in diesen
gruppen die besonders schnell aus und
das haben wir in einigen bundesstaaten
in den vereinigten staaten gesehen eher
lauter war sie stehen mitten drin in der
kritik und das tolle ist dass sie sich
dieser kritik tatsächlich stellen und
genau dieses streitgespräche zu lassen
wenn sie es immer für falsch gehalten
haben dass schulen geschlossen werden
und wenn ich nicht die letzten
anderthalb jahre tief geschlafen war
schulen ja beschlossen zulasten von
eltern zu lasten von vätern und müttern
zu lasten der kinder
ich finde sogar zu lasten der lehrer
obwohl man das vielleicht
unterschiedlich sinke die waren ja
geschlossen wo war denn dann der karl
lauterbach der alle menschen erreicht
dem alle zuhören der 80 millionen
zuhörer hat der gesagt hat jetzt sind
wir auf dem falschen weg macht sie
wieder auf das habe ich doch gerade
gesagt ich habe immer wieder sogar in
ihrem sender
immer wieder dafür plädiert doppelte
testo wechsel unterricht dann ist der
unterricht möglich sieben der kinder das
ist unstrittig die sich infizieren
entwickeln longo wie zentrum das ist
keine kleinigkeit woher kann herr
lauterbach diese sieben prozent aus der
ons studie das ist publiziert worden
aber tatsächlich die einzige studie die
es gibt also die systematisch quasi
repräsentativ alle auswertet wie
übrigens so oft wenn dieser pannen dies
ist die britische studie und die
britische eu us-studie ja dass du diesen
wert gegeben
die intensivbetten da haben sie eine
aussage getroffen da wollen wir auch
gleich noch mal reinschauen
da haben sie sich schon relativ konkret
festgelegt was die altersgruppe betrifft
die jetzt oder zu diesem zeitpunkt
gerade besonders auf den intensivbetten
liegt und ich glaube das könnte der
punkt sein die sie eben gerade
angesprochen haben wo man sagen könnte
da lagen sie dann doch phänomen
phänomenal falsch lassen uns da einmal
reinschauen wenige sind es oft wenn sie
sich das
die sind im durchschnitt etwa 47 48
jahre alt das sind menschen mitten im
leben die baten wir fünf sechs wochen
lang und viele von denen die hälfte
ungefähr von den voll beatmeten stirbt
das ist eine tragödie
und da verlieren viele kinder derzeit
ihre eltern zu diesem zeitpunkt gab es
gar nicht sein
genau das ist der einzige punkt das so
sie haben wir eine reihe von ihnen
vorgeworfen und sie maßen könnte ich
also etwas sagen wo ich glaube das nicht
also das sah man nicht wirklich so
stimmt und also überzogen ist und das
war offensichtlich frage also die
indische variante 20 prozent ansteigt da
in unsere ohren sind noch die warnung
vor der britischen mutante worauf
stützen sie sich haben sie da
erkenntnisse die eine solche warnung
stützen
ja das ist natürlich also eine typische
also aussage die ich mache ich studien
basiert ist das ganz klar sondern wir
haben sie das möchte ich einmal ganz
kurz wissen haben sie den einen forscher
jetzt gesucht der das sagt und dann
virus also verhält sich in deutschland
nicht anders als in england oder in den
vereinigten staaten oder kanada ganz
herzlichen dank dafür dass sie ja ich
tapfer waren aber vor einigen diesen
streit reingegangen sind letzte frage
ganz kurz sind sie eigentlich ein corona
populist würden sich als solchen
bezeichnen
in afghanistan ich bin krank corona
populisten also ich erkläre immer auf
der grundlage von studien nicht versuche
das darzustellen und also die zwei oder
drei äußerungen also diese ebene
gebracht haben noch nicht als populisten
ich sage mal vorzuführen
wir sind erstens nicht repräsentativ und
zum zweiten also ich bemühe mich
wirklich differenziert zu erläutern
das ist die studien da gedacht ist was
man machen kann und zwar so empfinde ich
mich nicht mehr
das wäre auch falsch wir sind bild und
wir liefern dir deine news auf youtube
zum nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren